وهذه صور تاتينا الان من العاصمه الخرطوم
نشاهد هناك نيران في السماء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم من المفترض ان هناك
هدنه
مستمره ولكن بين الحين والاخر هناك
اختراقات تتم لهذه الهدنه نحن نشاهد اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هناك اتصالات من قبل عدد من الدول
العربيه والاقليميه لمحاوله اتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار يستمر لمده اسبوع والمصادر
تشير الى ان هناك موافقه مبدئيه من
الجنرلين حميدتي والبرهان على هذه الهدنه
لكن لا تفاصيل حتى اللحظه حول طبيعه
التفاهمات التي تتم لبدء هذه الهدنه
المصادر تشير انها من المفترض ان تبدا بعد
ثلاثه ايام
هذه صور تاتينا وهي صور خاصه لنا وحصريه
للعربيه على
هذه الاعمده من الدخان التي تتصاعد في
سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ومصادر
العربيه تشير الى ان الطيران الحربي
استهدف مواقع عده للدعم السريع بمحيط مطار
الخرطوم مطار الخرطوم من المناطق الساخنه
التي ما زالت تشهد مواجهات مستمره رغم
الهدنه بين قوات الدعم السريع وما بين
الجيش السوداني ايضا محيط
القياده العامه
وما زلنا نتابع مع حضراتكم هذه الصور التي
تاتينا لتصاعد اعمده الدخان في سماء
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث طيران
الجيش استهدف مواقع عده للدعم السريع
بمحيط مطار الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات